welcome back here on the Rich Eisen show
to Marlon Wayans good to see you sir um
thank you for having me every time I
come here I used to steal a cup and she
do I have three of them now it's y'all
need to get new cups because I'm people
is looking weird now I look like I still
cook you know at some point what points
at two or three to two it's just like
hey you have a couple three now you're
the three it's like because now it's
like I'm one short of a set so they're
like did you steal four and you drop one
like it's confusing when you cut them
off I think you should change them up
just so I can have a new set I don't
know it's just every time every now and
then we look at each other like what
happened to our mugs are you saying we
have solved them the great mug caper
mystery all I'm saying is I like to take
souvenirs from places that have business
you lucky you got the table stuff so
what did you make of the NBA Finals
sir what did you make of LeBron getting
swept 400 no I well I like the way you
phrase that it's not that he got swept
it's just that he played the Monstars
from Space Jam and they added Kevin
Durant and when you do that chances are
and then you get Jared Smith apparently
yes found some really good cannabis and
made a terrible decision
you can't legalize weed wherever he's at
and I had some gummy gummy weed candies
[Laughter]
cheap like cannabis Gatorade and he took
a bad sip and that was a bad mistake
because I think if they would have won
that game would have been confidence for
the team
I agree I think it's the tea - it's too
much they assemble the team like the
LeBron killer's it's just not fair it's
not fun for me as a basketball fan to
watch a team of that caliber play
anybody a Monstars they like it it's not
fun like it's so good Golden State
Warriors is so good first of all I don't
know Steph Curry
did he they made him in a laboratory you
can't mix he's like the perfect of both
races he has the dribbles of a brother
and the jump shot of a white boy this
this he's the perfect like it's this bad
and then you can't the Kevin Durant look
how happy it's no stress no more he
knows he's gonna win Kevin Durant's hair
was receding he built in Golden's in an
Oklahoma City because it was problems
whose every night look at his hair now
he grew his hair back how your hair grow
back cuz he won no stress look at the
bronze
he's never a terrible hair year terrible
he does actually you know what my wife
and I were thinking that just the other
day watching they're watching the NBA
but the man has given his hair to the
sport and I love him for that he he
works every night look at Ovechkin that
man gave his teeth to 56 of his teeth he
has a baby tooth he and again fix
Ovechkin got a baby tooth it does a
wisdom tooth grown in the front Marlon
Wayans here on the Rich Eisen show so
you would have a problem with LeBron
created his own Super T no man I think
LeBron should go to either Philly or he
should go to Houston what about here to
the Lakers what about here the Lakers if
Kawhi is free somehow to be acquired and
I come here and they call Paul George
they tell Chris Paul don't sign in
Houston come come back to Los Angeles
yes I still think that team I think that
team doesn't have enough perimeter I
think what makes Golden State tough I
mean unless you beat them on the inside
you just completely you know work that
way
what makes go to say toughest you got
Steph Curry who's a threat from from
half-court the guys official threat then
you have just when you try to stop him
now you got Kevin Durant you got a
double-team him and now you got guys
like it with dolla that could shoot a
three now you've got klay Thompson that
could fire from anywhere Tremont - dream
on - well his three look someone said
Drake Mons three-point shot look like
he's shooting it with a book bag on it
looked crazy looks crazy itlet's cuz it
looks like it's a line drive looks like
someone popped
and the top is like he hit his head on a
ceiling as he was throwing a shot but I
just think that I mean you could come to
LA but I don't know I think I don't know
but I think if you do come to LA I think
you can need some some speed and some
more three-point right yeah
marlon wayans here on the Rich Eisen
show did you see the pot the Phil
Mickelson putt that everybody's talking
about right now I don't know how much of
a player a golf is why you can't come to
the Lakers because of Mickelson or know
LeBron the LeBron it just hit me okay
here's why it's bad for his business you
can't come to where Kobe just smashed LA
you were coming into Kobe's jetwash it's
not a good look
Kobe and magic on the Lakers
LeBron you don't have enough time to
secure your legacy here as a Laker so I
would say assemble that team in
Cleveland what about Clint what about
clippers you want to come in Los Angeles
that that may be better but Clippers
traded away everybody Clippers got rid
of everybody put Blake somewhere did it
whoo they got now they got DeAndre they
got Tobias Harris right I'm not missing
anybody I like DeAndre I like DeAndre
but you got to teach that man some foul
shots
it's like Shaq bit him shoot foul shots
what you gonna do is you got to
completely miss all the baskets you
gotta just don't worry about a shooter
flat you wanna shoot 40% from the line
that's a good Shaq by the way thank you
what's your best tip imitations you have
I was about to say you don't really you
don't strike me I do isms
I don't do sort of shock ISM
and you know yeah Phil Mickelson don't
medicine golf shot in that lab you all
[ __ ] didn't look like this this
tournament looked like Charles Barkley
and taught him how to play oh you got
the Charles Barkley swing what is going
on and then the run to the little man
that the dad jogged he's clearly
dehydrated like who does that I don't
know that was really bizarre I think he
called Tyga was like amen what's this
question Joey can you give me a batch
hashtag too soon so you're saying
probably Marlon Wayans on Twitter so
let's talk about season two of Marlon
yeah on NBC yes to back 9:00 to 9:30
yes a show based on my life yes as a
divorce
inappropriate dad that's just trying to
keep his family together in the midst of
a divorce and although the shows about
divorce that's the backdrop it's really
about love and family and it's
aspirational show because just cuz you
and your ex break up it doesn't mean
that your family's broken up well me and
my ex broke up
I did something I started literally
dating my family and I'm probably closer
with them now than I was before the
split so it's a beautiful thing and so I
take this show enough I want to want the
world to have what I have because it
feels good and these are truthful true
stories and it's a really funny show to
have any or any of your actual family
members gonna mix my sister Kim is
actually going to be on this week's
episode at nine o'clock okay and then we
have two special guests Sherri Shepherd
and Kym Whitley who are not related
that's gonna be in the second episode
playing my sisters so this week is a
really strong wheat with great guest
casting so make sure you guys tune in
because it's only five weeks and it's
back to back so you could blink you like
you could go get a tan for the summer
come back and be like Mullens season and
and if you want to find season one yeah
season one is on Netflix season two is
on NBC season one is on Netflix you can
binge watch it see if you like it and
then tune in to NBC this Thursday at
9:00 and 9:30 are you finding the
information I know but I was looking for
right now was I'm doing a lot of touring
right now because I did my special for
Netflix called walkush okay mom is busy
and so Marlin got some tour dates he's
gonna tell you by the way there's a
third person promotion well I don't like
to call me me when I talk about me when
I'm promoting because then it looks like
I'm promoting myself you see see the
mind game right there actually I'm I'm
I'm I'm like running after that pub
right right right don't talk about you
talk about you you're gonna say Rich
Eisen okay right there well you sucked
about Rich Eisen I want you to call you
rich Island don't say me well we're
talking to two people who ever show what
with their own name in it which is
really narcissistic exactly we cancel
each other out and make one humble
person you know the problem is I think
we're both scared that we know we're not
that good-looking
and that excuse me sir speak for
yourself well I'm speaking for you
because you can't speak for you because
you're rich Eisen okay and you're gonna
look narcissistic so I'm a suite for you
and I say we're both not that
good-looking
so we want to make sure that they don't
replace us so if we call the show the
Rich Eisen show us they can't replace
you with like some strange person from
like yes that is true exactly that is
all true and if I call me more of the
Marlin show yes you can't replace me
with like all the other thousands of
Wayans is that you can replace me Shawn
the Tim Tito Jackie Jermaine you got
there's only one morning okay very good
so yes that's it I'm gonna be June 22nd
at Casino Rama and Toronto June 23rd at
the Kasia Creek Casino and Brooks
California June 12 to the 15th American
comedy club in San Diego June ly 26
through 29th Caroline's in New York City
and lastly August 3rd through 5th at the
funny bone in Liberty Township
Cincinnati Ohio
fun stuff good to see you mom brother
you look good you
thank you I think you should grow the
hair all the way back I said I you know
I'm not like Durant I just can't do it
and then grow the beard I like the beer
gang okay thanks though a little bit of
like the five minute die in it right now
looks like a raccoon jumped on your face
and what you want to do is just let that
grow a little while now you got swag and
get a barber make sure he's a brother
and he slides you up so you got that
James Harden what he said okay fantastic
Marlon Wayans on Twitter check out
Marlon Thursday nights 9:30 after nine
o'clock back to back right here on the
show good to see you sir hey man great
see you guys steal this Cup please take
it that makes a nice set it's a four
pack for Marlon Wayans the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience